[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben schön dass sie wieder
dabei sein ich zeige euch heute wie ihr
bei euch zuhause eure eigene benjamin
blümchen torte machen könnt zuallererst
wird der boden vorbereitet dafür
benötigen wir 60 gramm zucker 120 gramm
weiche butter und 180 gramm mehl
[Musik]
die weiche butter gebe ich zusammen mit
dem drucker in eine schüssel und
verknetet das ganze mit den händen
dazu gebe ich dann das mehl und knete so
lange weiter bis ich einen schönen
festen tag bekomme
am einfachsten ist das wenn ihr den tag
auf der arbeitsfläche weiter knetet und
wenn dann ein schöner tag entstanden ist
dann kommt das in eine frischhaltefolie
wird etwas platt gedrückt und kommt dann
für eine stunde in den kühlschrank nach
der schulzeit ist der mürbeteig sehr
hart dann müsst ihr ihn einmal
auseinander brechen und zügig mit den
händen zu einer homogenen masse zusammen
kneten
[Musik]
der nachmittag auf etwas mehl aufgerollt
anschließend nehme ich mit meinen back
ring zu hilfe die mich auf 20 zentimeter
eingestellt habe um einen kreis
auszustechen
den gebe ich dann auch meine backpapier
und nehme mir dann eine gabel zu hilfe
um dort ein paar löcher einzustechen
damit der mürbeteig im ofen nicht
hochgeht und der wird jetzt bei 190 grad
ober unterhitze 14 minuten lang gebacken
in der zwischenzeit mache ich schon mal
die show kämen dafür benötige ich 180
gramm voll mit kuvertüre 100 gramm
besiegten puderzucker 60 gramm weiche
butter rund 130 g saure sahne
hierfür wird als erstes über einem
wasserbad die kuvertüre mit der brutal
geschmolzen und anschließend verrührt
[Musik]
anschließend das ganze nochmal ca 10
minuten lang auskühlen lassen
danach kommt die saure sahne hinein und
wird mit dem handmixer kurz verrührt und
[Musik]
zuletzt kommen noch der puderzucker dazu
und wird noch mal unter gemixt dadurch
dass wir das mit dem handmixer
aufschlagen wird die konsistenz der
creme etwas flüssiger die schokocreme
ist jetzt fertig und kann auf
zimmertemperatur erstmal beiseite
gestellt werden und solange geht es
weiter mit der erdbeer creme dafür
benötigen wir 400 gramm mascarpone 700
milliliter kalte schlagsahne 180 gramm
erdbeer marmelade eurer wahl zwei
teelöffel vanille extrakt ca 15
teelöffel sonderfahrt und 30 gramm
puderzucker zuallererst wird die sahne
mit 7 telefon seiner platscht eis
geschlagen
ihr könnt euch das auch so merken dass
pro 100 milliliter sahne immer ein
teelöffel salz benötigt wird
[Musik]
bis zur weiterverarbeitung gebe ich die
schlagsahne jetzt erstmal in den
kühlschrank
danach schlage ich in einer separaten
schüssel mascarpone puderzucker und
vanille extrakt für ein paar sekunden
lang geschmeidig damit sich die
marmelade besser in der creme verteilen
lässt werde ich jetzt noch einmal kurz
kurieren
[Musik]
die gebe ich jetzt auch noch mit zu
mascarpone und lasse sie für ein paar
sekunden lang unter rühren
[Musik]
dazu gebe ich noch den restlichen teil
des line ups und je mehr ihr hier
verwendet umso fester wird die krähen
[Musik]
bevor ich jetzt noch die sahne
unterheben gebe ich noch etwas früh
seine lebensmittelfarbe in meinem leben
[Musik]
und zum schluss nur noch die sahne
unterheben und dann ist die erdbeer team
auch schon fertig
[Musik]
des weiteren habe ich hier einen betritt
boden gebacken das video dazu verlinke
ich euch in die infobox ich habe hier
ein drittel des rezept in meiner 18 cm
springform gebacken
für die zusammensetzung der torte hier
nochmal alles im überblick einmal den
mürbeteig boden zwei esslöffel aprikosen
konfitüre die wir darauf geben werden
dann den biskuit worden
den habe ich hier bereits durch zwei
geteilt außerdem noch die erdbeer creme
und die schokocreme am besten
funktioniert das ganze auf einer
drehbaren tortenplatte da gebe ich jetzt
auf dem boden die aprikosen konfitüre
darauf gebe ich dann einen meiner
biscuit böden und drückt das etwas an
und wie im original haben wir hier
zwischen betritt boden und auch etwas
abstand
schließlich kommt die schokocreme zum
einsatz die habe ich hier in einem
spritzbeutel gefüllt so lässt sich das
ganze viel besser auftragen
auch hier gebe ich wieder etwas in die
mitte und lasse wieder ein bisschen
abstand zwischen biscuit roden und
problem
[Musik]
und wem die erste schicht jetzt auch zu
wenig war besitzt einfach noch eine
schicht obendrauf und streicht das ganze
dann noch mal glatt damit die ränder
auch schön glatt verstrichen werden kann
man hier zu hilfe eine biegsame teil
karte verwenden
[Musik]
lasst das einmal kurz für 15 minuten
durch kühlen und machte dann weiter mit
dem zweiten bestritt boden den setze ich
darauf und drücke das noch mal an
jetzt kommt die erdbeer creme zum
einsatz die wird an den rand der schoko
creme gespritzt und anschließend schön
glatt gestrichen hier eignet sich zum
beispiel sehr gut eine winkel palette
da kann man noch mal richtig schön
bequem reingehen doch anstatt auch keine
luftlöcher da sind
[Musik]
anschließend gebe ich den tortenring um
einen mürbeteig und weil wir dann noch
lücken zwischen haben geben wir die
crema komplett an den rand und auf die
oberfläche
[Musik]
dabei bleibt ein teil der 10 erhalten
also ihr benötigt nicht alles von der
creme und anschließend könnt ihr die
oberfläche mit einer winkel palette
glatt streichen und das ganze für 30
minuten in den kühlschrank geben damit
auch schön fett wird nach der kür zeit
ist die torten creme relativ fest dann
kann man einmal den tortenring von der
torte entfernen und die seiten weiter
bearbeiten
ihr könnt dafür die komplette restliche
creme verwenden und dann einfach so
lange glattstreichen bisschen zufrieden
weil bis zur weiteren verarbeitung kommt
die torte jetzt noch einmal in den
kühlschrank und in der zwischenzeit zu
mache ich mich um den benjamin da gibt
es verschiedene möglichkeiten dafür wird
eine oblate benötigt wie findet ihr in
jedem supermarkt nimmt dafür die etwas
größeren und nicht klein und eine
benjamin vorlage die ihr dann einfach
aus dem internet ausdrucken am besten
funktioniert das meiner meinung nach mit
einem zahnstocher und schwarzer
lebensmittelfarbe bei gutem wetter
eignet sich perfekt ein fenster dafür
oder wenn ihr habt ein glas tisch in dem
ihr ein licht untendrunter stellt dann
wird nur noch die mütze und das oberteil
rot eingezeichnete mit roter
lebensmittelfarbe und dann ist der
benjamin auch schon fertig
[Musik]
der kommt jetzt einmal mittig auf die
torte und anschließend nehme ich mir
einen runden ausstecher und markieren
die stellen auf den ich die seine
truppen möchte für den nächsten schritt
einfach die auf geschlagene sahne mit
hilfe eines spritzbeutel auf die torte
geben ich habe vorne einfach spitze weg
geschnitten dann habt ihr schöne runde
truppen und dazwischen gebe ich noch mal
kleinere wanne punkten
[Musik]
und abschließend fehlt nur noch das
konfetti auf der original benjamin
blümchen torte nur rosa gelb und grüne
konfettis sind habe ich mir die aufgabe
herausgepickt und gehen sie jetzt noch
auf die torte
[Musik]
dies ist das endergebnis meiner benjamin
blümchen torte ich schneide sie
natürlich auch für euch an damit ihr
seht wie sie im innern aussieht
[Musik]
und ich wollte die torte so original wie
möglich aussehen lassen deshalb ist mein
moden auch größer als der blitzkrieg
boden und deshalb geht bei mir die
schokocreme auch nicht ganz bis zum rand
jetzt zeige ich euch nochmal die
original benjamin blümchen torte neben
dem nachgemachten und hier seht ihr auch
wieder die einzelnen schichten
das war das erste video zu meiner
coppenrath & wiese auf meinem kanal und
es werden noch viele weitere folgen
falls euch das video gefallen hat freue
ich mich natürlich immer sehr über euren
kommentar über eure daumen und natürlich
auch über ein abo und ich sag bis zum
nächsten mal objektiv kitchen
[Musik]